welcome back to street smart as
Washington works to shrink the deficit
taxing the rich and entitlement programs
are coming under closer scrutiny this
time for reality check with Veronique de
Russia she's senior research fellow for
the Mercatus Center and Veronique good
to have you back with awesome let's kick
it off with your first myth and that is
millionaires who are in favor of an
income tax increase our fiscal heroes
you say the fact is many of the
super-rich see virtually all their
income as capital gains and dividends
rather than ordinary income we're going
to bring up a bar chart that really
shows I guess basically the rich versus
the poor so tell us how this kind of
supports what you say is the fact here
but that's not the right chart but the
chart that I had basically was showing
that as income increases the portion of
the income American make through wages
and saraly decreases and the very
wealthy gets draw most of their income
from dividend capital gain and interest
so basically when the when the rich
people this is their chart and you can
see basically the people who are very
rich I mean the blue part is really
significant so basically when you know
Mark Zuckerberg Zuckerberg of Facebook
once says he's cool was increasing the
income tax rates he is really cool of
increasing taxes on people who make much
less money than he does let's go on a
bit number two here the myth is that big
government means more redistribution of
wealth to the poor and you say the fact
is big governments tend to be less
progressive we have a chart that's a
line chart here who's paying the taxes
when he walk us through it so yeah still
not the right chart but the if you look
at the share of income paid by French
people versus American Enka American
people as by level of income what you
see is two important things at all level
of income
french workers pay significantly bigger
share of their income in taxes and
Americans and the other most important
is a contrary to common belief the
American tax system is way more
progressive than the French system so it
means that higher income people in
France pay a smaller share of their
income in taxes than the lower income
people and friends and you know it and
we apologize that very day because we
know the charts of bananas or this it
must be some ghosts out there hey listen
let's get to the a chart i think we
brought up initially and that was
dealing with social security the myth is
the doomsday projections of social
security and medicare spending are
overstated you actually say the fact is
on top of the spending that's supposedly
supposedly funded the unfunded
liabilities for Social Security and
Medicare exceed one full year of u.s.
gdp it's staggering we've got a chart
and hopefully will be the right one it's
a bar chart and it's showing funding
Social Security and Medicare will get it
for you but talk to us about what you
say is the fact here first well so the
red part of the chart shows the unfunded
liability and it's for Medicare and
Social Security and it's a rosy scenario
and it shows it's 21 trillion dollars of
promises that are not backed by any
dedicated taxes right unfunded liability
and you if you contrast this by roughly
the size of the gdp which is 15 trillion
dollars what this means is that if you
confiscate an entire year of wealth
produced by Americans corporation
individuals and you put it in those
trust funds this still will not be
enough to pay for all the promises that
are unfunded and that have been made all
right the numbers definitely it's
staggering it is staggering it is
staggering all right really with their
veronique thanks so much for patients
with that verdict guruji over at the
mercatus center